to present the awards for music scoring  a nominee for his performance in the man  with the Golden Arm mr. Frank Sinatra  well the best scoring on a musical  picture and the winner is  Oklahoma Robert Russell Bennett J  Blackson and a dog toys  laid off doing  Gerry we can keep the other two that's  three more names who will keep them  oh yeah I'll hold it right all right  thank you for the picture  yes no no no this is for the best music  score of a dramatic or comedy picture I  have the envelope certainly I see no  reason why you should love is a  many-splendored thing  no papi  I'm very grateful to everybody thank you  right from jest you've got it made you  just can't go to a theater anywhere in  the whole world we're a picture of yours  isn't playing tell me how many pictures  do you make this year who counts the  government good ol Uncle Sam he's really  the man with the Golden Arm ad nothing